mike clevenger goes to work against hey
eugenio's suarez
swings at the first pitch and a nice
play by carlos santana closing that gap
on the
right side of the infield he was the
only guy over there so he had a big gap
to close the two-strike pitch swing and
a miss struck him out oh that's
catcher's interference oh gecko's
interference
oh he hit his arm
he actually hit hit just below his elbow
it looked like
way out in front of the plate leon does
a great job to block it they've got the
runner senzelle hung up and run down
nice lindor quickly applies the tag and
winker cannot score from third so there
are two down
and now a chance to end the inning if
clevenger can get van meter
struck him out looking and van meter
remains hitless
on the young season second game for
clevenger
indians come to bat against cj antone in
the bottom of the second inning he balls
two strikes santana wade santone
got him to chase up and away his pitch
swing and a miss got him to chase that
breaking ball on the dirt outside and it
comes and a swing and a miss a filthy
slider away and luplow is down on
strikes antone fans three one down for
shogu akiyama
that ball is hit and driven hard by
akiyama it'll be played off the wall out
there by luplow and the reds are going
to hold galvez at third base
so a double by shogo akiyama the other
way and now the reds in business so here
comes vato
a swing and a high drive to left field
not deep toward the line is luplow he'll
make the catch and good pitching by
clevenger and he gets out of the inning
and now jose ramirez the batter the
pitch a swing by ramirez and a weak fly
into shallow center and it is dropping
between everybody
and the indians load them up on a bloop
single to center between
the shortstop galvez and the center
fielder senzel
frankie lindor will bent with the bases
loaded
ground ball right to second base onto
galves on devato that's a double play
yeah baby that's what i'm talking about
four six three inning
tucker barnhart leg kick in the pitch
swung on and that's looped to the third
baseman on the short hop picked up by
ramirez throws on the run and he gets
him at first base on a close play oh
that's a dandy of a defensive play by
ramirez that ball just floated out there
to the third base side of the mound and
ramirez came charging in there was a
little english on it but he was able to
pick it with the glove on the backhand
and still throw out barnhart cj antone
goes to work here in the bottom of the
fifth inning
[Applause]
lotto will take the out the right-handed
thrower gets it right there where he was
you know he's not going to be able to
throw it can get in the throwing lane if
he fields it and immediately throws the
second that's a different story now you
come back you take a guy out of the
bullpen for his first major league start
and antone goes four and a third innings
of two hit shutout baseball cesar has
found his new digs to his liking he's on
seven for 20.
hard hit ground ball in the hole coming
around third luplow will be waved home
akiyama's throw to the plate not in time
in the indian strike first here at
inning number five
cesar hernandez with his third run
batted in on the year a perfectly placed
rbi single so the indians on the board
and now jose ramirez steps in with
runners at first and second
yeah
galvez goes to second they get the out
there coming home mercado the throw
safe at the play what a slide by oscar
mercado it looked like he was going to
be a dead duck but he got down and got
the hand under the glove and the indians
steal a run here and make it two to
nothing that's just great hustle i love
what van meter did he fake the throw to
first base and mercado didn't hesitate
to work here
throw it out of first it was close oh he
got him
he got him yeah he did jerry meals did
call him out they're gonna have to check
it out let's see if he blocks it carlos
blocks the bag from his hand getting in
yeah that's a tough one to get uh
overturned
the pitch and he missed inside went with
another breaking ball three walks in the
inning five in the games that's going to
be it for clevenger but dominic leon now
takes over on the mound for
the cleveland idiots
swung out and missed dominic leone slams
the door on the reds here in the city
andy alamar went to the heart throwing
righty james karen check
ground ball turn it hernandez to ramirez
back to santana it's an inning ending
double play brad hand coming on here in
the ninth
that time he did not get the benefit of
the doubt meaning suarez and he's out
looking kirk casalli will get an
opportunity
here's the pitch
strike three called back door slider
ball game
and brad hand dominates for the second
night nero the indians pitched their
third shutout of the year and beat the
cincinnati reds two to nothing